The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
COLIN SHEPPARD: OK, so for
the ones that just arrived,
I'm going to be giving
the lecture today.
But George is here.
So if you've got
questions, you can ask me.
I don't mind being
interrupted at any time.
But also, if you want
George to answer something,
he's sitting here as well.
So he can also contribute.
So last time, George was looking
at the Fourier transforming
property of a lens.
And he looks at the--
derived the 1D case, where
you've just got a function of, x
rather than a function of x, y.
You've got this
transparency a distance z
in front of the lens.
And then you've got a
screen placed a distance
f behind the lens.
And so the question is, what
do you get on that screen?
And I'm not going to go
through all the algebra of that
again because George
did it last time.
This was the calculus.
This was the answer.
What you find is that what
you get in this plane here
is actually the
Fourier transform
of the thin transparency.
So g of x is this
transparency here.
You get the Fourier
transformer that.
And multiplied by
a parabolic phase
factor, which depends on the
position of this screen--
of the transparency.
What is the value of this z?
You'll notice that you get this
factor here, 1 minus z over f.
So if z equals f,
this is going to be 0.
And this phase factor
is going to disappear.
So for the special
case where z equals
f, all you see here is just
the Fourier transform of this.
Very simple-- very
simple answer.
And people actually have known
this for quite a long time.
And at one time, it did
look really attractive
that you could
actually imagine using
this as a real way of
doing Fourier transforms.
Especially as we're
now going to do,
you can immediately generalize
that to the 2D case.
So you can do a 2D
Fourier transform.
And when you think that the
light propagates through this
at the speed of light, you
can do a 2D Fourier transform
at the speed of light.
And when people
first realized this,
which was back in the 1950s--
'50s or early '60s, computers
were very slow then.
So doing a 2D Fourier
transform was not trivial.
So a lot of effort was put into
trying to design instruments
to do that.
Yes.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Do you
know who was the first one
to realize this?
Was it Vander Lugt?
COLIN SHEPPARD: The
question is, who was
the first to recognize that?
Yeah Vander Lugt was
at Michigan, wasn't he?
And interestingly,
the holography guys
were also in the same lab.
What's the guy's name.
The one-- Emmett Leith.
And interestingly, Emmett
Leith and Vander Lugt
both published virtually the
same paper in the same year.
It's a very, very interesting
historical thing there.
They're both from the
same lab, and they both
invented almost the same
idea as far as I can see.
And neither of them
referred to the other guy.
Very peculiar.
Anyway, I don't know who really
came up with this idea first.
But actually, I suspect that
actually, even Ernst Abbe
realized this.
Ernst Abbe was the scientist who
designed the Zeiss microscopes
120, 130 years ago.
And he came up with a
theory for image formation
in a microscope,
which is actually
what we're going to
be getting onto pretty
well, the next thing--
the imaging with a 4F F system.
He understood that
130 years ago.
And I don't think he's often
given as much credit is
he should get.
Anyway, you can
use this as a way
of doing a Fourier transform,
and even a 2D Fourier
transform.
So you see, going
from this stage
to this stage is
trivial, really.
All we've done here
is assuming that it's
a separable function
of x and y so you
get exactly the same
sort of integral for y
as you get for x.
So it now becomes
a double integral.
This is the two-dimensional
Fourier transform object
of g of x, y.
And you can see, you get
again the phase factor.
Here, because it's
separable, you've
got this e to the
i pi x squared,
and you got an e to
the i pi y squared.
And of course, x squared
plus y squared very nicely
equals r squared.
So this becomes a
spherical type wave.
So we've still got this 1 minus
z over f So if z equals f,
then again, this
phase factor vanishes,
and we end up with just
the pure Fourier transform.
Yeah, as I say,
so a lot of people
thought that this
was quite a neat way
of doing Fourier transforms.
There was a lot of work
on optical computers
all the way through
the '60s and '70s.
But the trouble is that, as
fast as they could develop
these systems, the
computer people developed
their computers even faster.
So they were always one
step behind, I think.
So I think in the
end, people realized
it was a waste of time,
and that it was never
really going to become
a practical way of doing
real calculations.
But in the early days, it was.
And Emmett Leith we
were just mentioning,
he first developed these
systems for actually
analyzing the images they
took from a synthetic aperture
They'd fly an aeroplane over
North Korea, taking pictures.
And then the idea was that
the plane takes many pictures
as it's traveling along, and
they're coherent with respect
to each other.
So you can actually combine
them digitally afterwards
and get an image, which
has got amazing resolution.
And you can see the guy in North
Korea reading his newspaper
or whatever.
So they really did that
sort of thing way back then.
Right, so that's the
equation here then.
And yeah, so this is
just going through how
that thing was derived.
So we've got the screen
here, the g of x.
By the time we get
here, it's convolved
with some parabolic
phase function.
And then after it
goes through here,
it's multiplied by another
parabolic phase function.
And then as it
propagates here, it's
convolved with another
parabolic phase function.
And if we have that magic
condition, that this is f
and this is f, most of these
parabolic phases cancel out
and we're left with this
very simple final answer.
So that's basically
what's happening.
And George went through the
various stages of doing this.
Of course, you end up with a
couple of integrals of products
of three phase functions here.
So the algebra process
was quite complicated.
Well, not really complicated,
but just lengthy.
But everything in
the end cancels.
If you haven't got z
equals 2f, though, then you
can see that you have
got this phase factor.
So you don't actually get
exactly the Fourier transform
in this plane in that case.
You get the Fourier
transform multiplied
by this phase factor.
And that can be
important in some cases.
That's something that you
need to take into account.
There's another
special case, actually.
That's the case when z equals 0.
The case when z equals
0 is if this screen
coincides with the lens--
immediately close
up to the lens.
And I think Goodman does
that one as well, doesn't he.
And so if z equals 0, this goes.
And so we're still left
with this phase factor,
e to the i pi x double
dash squared over lambda f.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
And also, Goodman
does the case of
the transparency
after the lens, which I
did not do in the notes.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right, OK.
Yeah, so Goodman does this
case of the transparency placed
in here.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That this is z negative.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, but
it's very similar answers.
OK, so this is just
writing down finally, then.
We're defining then the Fourier
transform of little g is big G.
So the final answer is that
you've got this parabolic phase
function times the
Fourier transform of g.
OK.
So this is pointing
out that we've now
looked at two different ways
you can do a Fourier transform.
One way is to just propagate
the light a very large distance.
You remember, if you have
[? frame ?] of a diffraction,
if your screen is a very long
way away from the diffracting
screen, object,
whatever it was called--
transparency then again,
you get this Fourier
transform relationship.
But of course, here he's
put a proportional side.
There's some things
out the front there.
And in particular, there's going
to be, again, a parabolic phase
term, isn't there?
Because in this case here,
what you'd expect actually
is that this
Fourier transform is
going to be actually on the
surface of some curved surface,
not of a plane surface.
So if the screen
is plane, then it's
going to be multiplied by
some parabolic phase term.
And now we've just looked
at this other case where
we don't have to have a
very large lab in order
to do this experiment.
We can actually make the
experiment quite small
so that it fits on top of the
table just by using a lens.
And really what you can see,
that that is actually doing,
according to your
geometrical optics ideas now,
you can see what this is doing.
This is producing an
image of this at infinity.
So you can see that these two
things are actually equivalent.
Well, what it's
doing is bringing
what would have been at
infinity to some finite plane.
So that's all it's doing there.
But again, we've got
this [? string ?]
here, this proportional
sign, which
means there's some other
constant factors out there,
including in general this
parabolic phase factor, which
for this particular case, when
you got f and f, it disappears.
The parabolic phase
function disappears
when you've got this very, very
special case with the two f's
there.
OK, now this one.
What this is really
trying to show
is that, really,
there's two ways
of looking at this problem.
These two diagrams
here are really
trying to show the
same case, but trying
to get you thinking about
a different way of viewing
the problem.
So in this case
here, you can think
of any point on the
screen on the transparency
is going to act
like a point source.
So it's going to produce a
spherical expanding wave.
And then this is a distance
f, so that spherical wave
is going to be
converted into a plane
wave The angle of propagation
of this plane wave
depends on the distance at
this point from the origin,
of course.
And so you can think, then,
of what you see on the screen
as being made up of
what's called an angular
spectrum of plane waves, where
the strength of each of those
and get a spectrum components
comes about from the value
of at that point.
So that's one way of
thinking about it.
And this way [INAUDIBLE]
thinking about it
the other way.
This way, you're
thinking of the object.
It's going to diffract.
If you imagine your transparency
as being like a grating,
it produces a diffraction.
It's producing
light grating orders
For example, if this
was a very simple case
of a sinusoidal
grating, you'd expect it
to produce some grating orders.
And these grating orders
correspond to plane waves
traveling in particular angles.
So this shows the
angular spectrum
of the diffraction of the light
given by the transparency.
And then the lens collects
these different plane
white components.
All of them are
going to be converted
into a spherical
converging wave that
converges a distance f away.
It doesn't say that, but
this must be [? there. ?]
And the plane wave's
moving at different angles
are going to converge to a
point which, of course, is
proportional to the sine of
the angle of the propagation.
So here, at any
point on the screen,
you're going to sum up
again these angular spectra
components, each of which is
going to give a spherical wave.
So you can see, looking
at that diagram again,
they're like inverses
of each other.
I think this is another
example where, very often, you
can think of a
reciprocal type behavior.
You could just flip
this over, and it would
look the same the other way.
OK, so this way
here, then, we're
thinking of this as just
like the Huygens sense
that we spoke about
when we were first
doing diffraction [? there. ?]
OK, so this is giving
some nice pictures.
I'm going to steal this
presentation afterwards,
because there's so many
good displays in this thing,
that I'm going to use it in
my own lectures in the future.
So this has given
me some good ideas.
So we start off, then,
this is a rectangle.
Oh, I'm going to say
something in a minute, though.
So this is a distance f.
This is a distance f.
So this length, then,
as we just described,
is going to produce a
Fourier transform of that.
So the Fourier transform
of rect is a is a sinc.
So you'd expect to get this a
sinc in x times a sinc in y.
Now, the thing I was going
to say though, George,
this looks to me that
this is longer than that.
This is longer this
way than that way.
So this should be longer that
way than this way, I think.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: That's
the aspect ratio of the screen
actually.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, the
aspect ratio of the screen
ought to be 90 degrees round.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: There's
not a [? way of the ?]
Fourier transform, I guess.
[LAUGHS]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Anyway, so
this conversation does bring it
home, I think, and
a very important
point that we've mentioned
before in the course.
That if you make a
function smaller,
it's Fourier transform is wider.
If you make the function
wider, this Fourier transfer
is smaller.
And you'll notice, then, these
products of these two sincs
gives a bright
spot in the center,
a series of bright
spots along the axes.
There are also some bright
spots in this region here.
But they're so weak that
you can't actually see them.
Really, you can only see
the ones along the axes.
All right, so that's
the first example.
Then this one's showing how,
if we make the transparency
smaller, the rectangle smaller,
so this pattern gets bigger,
now actually we can
just about manage
to maybe see some ones
other than along the axis.
And then this one is
an interesting one.
So now we've got not just one
aperture, but three apertures.
And so how can we work out
what the Fourier transform
of three apertures would be?
Anyone got some ideas?
I'm sure [INAUDIBLE]
will have an idea.
Anyone?
How would anyone think of
doing this sort of thing?
Have you come across a thing
called the convolution theorem?
Probably you should
have done somewhere,
I would have thought.
So there's the thing
in Fourier transforms
called convolution theorem.
So this is actually, like,
three spikes convolved
with a square, which
really all it means
is we place a square on
each of the three spikes.
And the convolution theorem
says that the Fourier transform
of a convolution is the product
of the Fourier transforms.
So what you'd expect is that the
Fourier transform that you're
going to see here is
the Fourier transform
of the rectangle, which is this,
multiplied by something else,
which is the Fourier
transform of the three spikes.
And the three spikes is
like a delta function
and a plus or minus
delta function.
The plus or minus delta
function together,
e to the i sampling plus
e to the minus i sampling
gives cause.
And the one in the center
just gives a constant.
So the Fourier transform of
these three delta functions
is 1 plus a cosine, or
something like that.
And so that's what we
expect to see, then.
This thing, this pattern
that we saw before,
is going to be multiplied
by a cosine function which
comes about because of
the separation of this.
And of course, because
this distance is actually
much bigger than the
width of the rectangle,
the spacing of the cosine is
much finer than the Fourier
transform of the rectangle.
And so that's why
these fringes--
you see these fringes,
very fine fringes,
they become a result of the
fact that these components here
are quite well-separated.
So that's another
very nice example.
And so all these theorems that
you learn in Fourier transforms
can all be directly
taken over into optics.
And sometimes, they
can save a lot of work,
because you can just use the
standard forms for things
that you can look up
in a book of tables.
And it saves you a lot of
algebra, or even worse,
arithmetic.
Right, so this is
another example.
So now we're back to the
bigger rectangle, or something
close to the bigger rectangle.
The Fourier transform of the
rectangle, we saw before.
But now this one, you see this
is multiplied by some fringes.
So this is like the opposite
of this one, really.
So this is a convolution.
This is a product.
So we use the same
convolution theorem again.
The fringes, of
course, correspond
just like we said before.
The Fourier transform of
the three delta functions
was the fringes.
So the Fourier transform
with the fringes
is like three delta functions.
So what we'd expect,
this is a product
of the fringes
and the rectangle.
So we expect here to see the
convolution of the Fourier
transform of the
fringes and the Fourier
transform of the rectangle.
And that's what we see.
So we see three of these
diffraction patterns situated
on these three spots
corresponding to the Fourier
transform of that grating.
So a very nice
display, that one.
I like that one.
OK, so this is now
introducing the idea
of what's called the 4F system.
So we're going to do this not
just once, but do it twice.
So this just shows
what we've had so far.
If we've got some
particular transparency,
we get some particular
diffraction pattern
in the back focal plane.
And then in the 4F system,
we do the same again.
We now have another
lens which is
going to do exactly the same.
It's going to look
at this pattern
and produce it's
Fourier transform.
So remember, if this is f
and this is f and this is f
and this is f, we won't
have to worry anything
about these parabolic phases.
It's just straight Fourier
transforms with nothing else.
And so you can see what you get.
It's very simple.
You start off with this object.
So here is Fourier transform
And if you take the Fourier
transform of the
Fourier transform,
what do you get if you do a
Fourier transform of a Fourier
transform?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
it's not quite, is it?
You remember?
You invert it.
That's right, Yeah,
so someone got that.
If you remember, if you do a
Fourier transform of a Fourier
transform, you get the
original function inverted.
You have to take the Fourier
transform four times,
and then you get back
to where you start.
And so that's what
we can see anyway.
So this is the inverted.
Well, of course, inverted,
that's just what we expect,
isn't it?
Because we know that when
we have an imaging system,
we get an inverted image.
So everything fits together.
It gives exactly
the same results
that we expect from
our geometrical optics.
And so in this case,
of course, this
is a rather symmetrical object.
So the fact that this
has been inverted,
I guess you can't
really even see.
OK, so this is
saying, then, that you
can make a 4F system
which produces,
then, an inverted version
of the original object.
You might wonder what
the point of that is.
I mean, I guess
in a way, there's
no point in making an
image which is much
the same as the object, really.
But one reason why
you might want--
well, there's two reasons.
One is that it's actually
produced this image
in a different plane.
So it's actually transported
this distribution of light
here from this
plane to this plane.
So that's one type
of application
where you might want to
do something like this.
And the second thing, of course,
is that although this is always
called a 4F system,
one we obviously
have to have this and this
[INAUDIBLE] both equal for this
to work.
We have to add this and this
f to be equal for it to work.
But this f doesn't have
to be the same as that f.
So you can actually
have a system
like this, where you actually
produce a magnified image
or a demagnified image.
And now, that, of course, is
getting a lot more useful.
So that's how you
can produce an image
of an object in another plane.
Now, the next thing
to note is, of course,
so far we've assumed
that all this light gets
through this optical
system and gets here.
So if that was the case,
you get a perfect image.
If all the information
from the objects
was getting to the image, then
you wouldn't lose anything.
But in practice, of course,
that's never going to be true.
And, well, one way it's not
going to be true, of course,
is because in practice,
these lenses are never
going to be infinitely large.
But also, we could,
if we wanted to,
actually put some sort
of mask in this plane
here to actually stop
some of that light getting
through to the image plane.
And so now we're going to look
at what happens if we do that.
This is much the
same overall effect
as George spoke about in
previous lectures, actually.
Not imaging case, but he
spoke about-- you remember
the results with the
building with the windows
that you could actually, just
by doing digital processing
on the Fourier
transforms, you can
manipulate the
strength of the grating
components in the final image.
So the same is true
here, except now we're
doing it optically
rather than digitally.
So what you'd expect, then, is
if we put something in here--
so here, this is
showing a passband.
So let's say you
put in here some--
a [? paint ?] screen
with a small hole in.
The hole is this passband, and
the screen is the block band.
So it only let's through
the region in the center.
According to how big
that passband is,
you'll get different
answers in the image plane.
Yeah, of course, it
says the transparency
may be a grayscale.
It doesn't have to be a binary
type thing, black and white.
Or it could even
be a phase mask.
It could be that this
is changing the phase
by, let's say, pi by 2 relative
to this or pi relative to this,
or whatever.
And you get different
answers according
to what you choose, obviously,
for the geometry of this
what we call spatial filter.
OK, so yeah, this is
going back to this idea
of these two ways of thinking
about the same problem.
So this is the first way,
where we think of our objects
as being made up of lots
of point scatterers Each
of these scatterers gives
rise to, like, Huygens'
spherical wavelets.
Each of these is
collected by lens.
The lens convert
that to a plane wave.
The plane wave reaches
the second lens.
And because it's
a plane wave, it's
converted back to a
spherical wave that converges
at distance f away from that.
And now we've actually
introduced the fact
that these f's
can be different--
so f1, f2.
This has to be equal
to this, and this
has to be equal to this.
Otherwise, the phases
won't cancel out properly.
And so you can see
that what you'd expect,
then, is that because
in this diagram here,
F1 is bigger than F2, this
image is actually smaller
than the original object.
And note now, you
can also see directly
the geometry showing
the inversion,
the point above the axis has
come to an image below the axis
here.
So that's the one way
of thinking about it.
And then the other way
is to think in terms
of spatial frequencies.
We think of this object as
being like a grating, which
is going to produce
grating orders which
travel in different directions.
Each of these grating
orders is like a plane wave.
And when it reaches
the lens, it's
going to produce a converging
spherical wave, which
comes to a focus at
distance f behind the lens.
And then after that, of
course, it doesn't stop.
But it carries on.
It diverges again,
reaches the second lens.
And then the second
lens, because this
is a spherical wave coming
from a distance f away,
is converted into
a plane wave again.
So again, you've got this nice
symmetry between what goes in
and what comes out.
So there are these
really different ways
of thinking about how
this is all going on.
End of show.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right then.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right, OK.
So all that was just a warm-up.
That was last week's lecture--
last Monday's lecture
we've done so far.
Right.
Oh, yes.
Lots of interesting
things coming up later.
OK, so we're going to
carry on straight away
with more of this 4F system
and spatial filtering.
So we're just getting
started on this.
And so there's lots of
very interesting things
you can do with these.
So this is back to the same
thing again [INAUDIBLE]
showing again, but a
bit more detail now,
because we're actually
going to really look
at more detail of where
these orders are formed
and what you can do with them.
So we have a grating object.
Let's imagine this is just
a 1 plus a cosine, which
means then it
produces a zero order,
and then a plus
and minus 1 order.
So three plane waves.
And as we said, each
of those plane waves
is going to be converted to
a converging spherical wave.
And so in this back
focal plane, you'll
see three spots corresponding
to the three orders.
And then carrying
on, these plane waves
then converted back
into a spherical wave.
And you get an image which
is back to the grating again.
So at the moment,
the optical system
has transmitted all
the information.
And so what we really
expect is that the image
is exactly the same as the
object, apart from the fact
it's inverted and it might be
magnified, or the opposite.
But the resolution you'd
expect would be the same.
All the detail in here,
you'd expect to see in there.
So the next thing
to look at is what
happens if we now
place something
in this plane that changes
the relative strength
of these different orders.
And there are lots of
things that we could try.
The first one, the
simplest one to look at,
is what happens if we just
put in something, a mask
here that lets through the
zero order and not the others.
The plus 1 and the minus 1 order
are obstructed by this screen.
So all we let through
is this single order,
which is going to be
converted to a plane wave.
And so on your screen here, all
you'll see is the plane wave.
So the image that you see--
well, I call it an image.
But it's not really
much of an image.
It's completely featureless.
It's just like a gray spot--
a gray region.
There's no detail there.
So we've lost that structure.
Actually, because we
put this mask in here,
the structure is beyond
the resolution limit
of the optical system.
And so we can't see it.
OK, so this is what we might
call a low-pass filter.
So if you think of these
as being like these grating
orders basically represent
different spatial frequencies.
So just in analogy with what
you have in electricity,
where you've got
frequencies and time,
in space, we've got distance and
we've got spatial frequencies.
So this is why we could talk
about low-pass filtering.
We're filtering the
spatial frequencies.
And just like in
time, you remember
when you've got
your hi-fi system,
if you turn down
the treble, that's
acting like a low-pass filter.
It's cutting out the
high-frequency sound
and letting through the
low-frequency sound only,
isn't it?
So that's what we call
a low-pass filter.
And this is exactly the same.
We've put in the mask.
It's a bit different in a
way from the electronic case,
because in optics, we've
got a lot more freedom
as to what we can do.
We can actually put in
something here which
has got real sharp edges to it.
In electronics, if you're
trying to make a filter,
there's always a
limit to how much
you can make the roll
off of the filter.
So you can't get something
that suddenly cuts off
like that very easily.
OK, so this is going
through the maths of this.
Our original transparency,
then, is a 1 plus cosine.
And the 1 plus cosine,
we Fourier transform
that to find what we
call the object spectrum.
And so in this case, finding
the Fourier transform of cosine
is very straightforward,
because we just
expand cosine as e to
the i something plus e
on the minus i something over 2.
And each of those e
to the i type terms
will correspond to
a single frequency.
So we end up now with three
terms at different frequencies.
The one Fourier transforms to
a delta function of u, which
is a spike where u equals 0.
And the two components
of the cosine
correspond to another 2 delta
functions, each situated--
this one's a u
equals some value u0.
And this one is some
value u equals minus u0.
So you've got these three spikes
that we've been talking about
for the last few slides now.
So this is the object spectrum.
It's the angular spectrum
that we've got here.
So actually, you can see that
u here basically represents
the angle that these plane
waves are traveling in.
And there's three
different angles
that the light can travel in.
And so yeah, that
will propagate, then.
And as we've said
before, you can
see that these rays
are moving at an angle.
And so as you go
along a distance f,
you get a shift
in the x position
which is given by, of
course, the slope of this.
The more the slope, the
more it deflects by the time
you travel a distance f.
So this then gives the
shifts of these two things.
So that's before
the screen, then--
sorry, before the mask.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Yeah, so this is showing, then--
so these raise, then,
as they come down here.
We put in this
pupil mask which is
going to get rid of these two.
And it just leaves
the other one.
So we just left them
with our single beam,
which as we said before gives
an image which is not really
an image.
Right, yeah, so
after the pupil mask,
we multiplied by the mask.
Gets rid of those two.
Just leaves the other one.
And finally, then, the
final image you'll see
is going to be the Fourier
transformer of that.
And the Fourier transform of the
delta function is a constant.
And so you see something
which has got no detail in it.
OK, so this gives
another example, then.
Here, we're looking at some
binary amplitude grating.
So this is a
particular example--
another example.
So last time, we looked
at the cosine type thing.
So this one is now
a binary grating,
which means that the
object is something
which is either black or white.
And we shine a light onto this.
So it's like a
square wave grating.
And so unlike the previous
case where cosine, of course,
just produced those
three grating components,
in this case, there's going
to be a whole load of grating
components.
They're going to go on forever.
But they get weaker and weaker.
And so you can see here,
it shows a few of them.
The first, the
second, so there'll
be the third, the
fourth, and so on.
And then minus 1,
and so on and so on.
And each of these is moving
at a different angle.
So when the plane wave
gets to the pupil mask--
sorry, when the plane wave
is focused to the pupil mask,
it's going to reach there.
At a point, the distance
from the axis, of course,
is going to depend on the angle
of this plane wave component,
the grating component.
So if you look
here, you're going
to see all these different
grating orders all
arrayed in this position here.
And so by putting some
sort of mask here,
we can monitor and change the
relative strength or phrase
or whatever we like of
those different components.
And then they'll
be added together,
produce some nice effect that
we might want to look at.
So let's see what we're
going to get in this case.
So in this particular
case in the picture,
the size of this
aperture is enough to let
through the central three
components, the zero order
and the plus and minus 1 order.
But it stopped all
the other ones.
So what you will see here is
the Fourier transform of this.
[INAUDIBLE] before.
It's these three spikes again.
The Fourier transform of
the three spikes is just a 1
plus a cosine.
The relative strength of
these might change according
to the properties of these--
of the transmission of the mask.
But anyway, what you see finally
is an object which is like--
you see the 1 plus cosine
type variation in amplitude.
And so you notice that
this thing here started
with these very square edges.
We no longer see the
very square edges.
So this is an example of
how we've lost resolution.
The optical system has got
a certain finite resolution.
There's detail in
this original object
that we can't actually
see in the final image.
And this is because
not all the light
has got through the system.
OK, so we're going to look
at a particular case now.
This is the bit I was saying
I wasn't very keen on.
No, no, it's all right.
But anyway, there's
a load of maths
here, which I might
actually gloss over a bit,
and let you look at
it yourself later.
But basically,
then, we're looking
at a particular example.
It's a binary grating with
perfect contrast, m equals 1--
i.e., this goes
from black to white.
That's what that means.
It's got a period of 10 microns.
The spacing, the
period, is the distance
between the repeat
on this grating.
And it's got a duty
cycle of a third, which
means that the white bit is
a third of the black bit.
Is that what that means?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: A
third of the whole.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
a third of the period.
OK, and then we're also told
that the 4F system consists
of two identical lenses of focal
length f equals 20 centimeters.
So both f1 and f2
are 20 centimeters.
And we put a pupil
mask of diameter
3 centimeters here
at the Fourier plane.
What is the intensity observed
at the output image plane?
So that's the question.
OK, the secrets to solve this
kind of problem, what you've
got to do is to
work out what you're
going to get in this
plane, which is basically
the Fourier transform of this.
And then you're going to
have to multiply by the mask
and see which of those
orders get through.
So the relative scaling of this
diffraction pattern in the mask
is obviously all
important for that.
If you don't get that
right, then you'll
get the wrong answer,
obviously, because you
might get orders getting
through that shouldn't,
or the other way around.
And so once we've done
that, we know now what
the grating orders, the Fourier
components in the final image,
are going to be.
And we then do another
Fourier transfer.
And we've got the
image amplitude.
There we are.
Again, we go [? do ?] scaling
to get it the right size.
Normally, of course,
at the very end,
we would be interested in
intensity, not amplitude,
as well.
OK, so this is our
example low-pass
filtering, a binary
amplitude grating.
So this is this grating
as we've chosen.
And so you can see this, that
the dimension's in microns.
So this is quite a fine grating.
So you can see that it's
not symmetrical, by the way.
The duty cycle is
not a half, right?
So the width of
the bright regions
is smaller than the width
of the dark regions.
And that's important
when it comes
to looking at the
Fourier transform,
and therefore the
spectrum of that.
And then the pupil
mask that we're
going to look at looks
something like that.
We let through the
frequencies near the center.
And we keep out--
reject the frequencies which
are further from the center.
OK, so for the Fourier
transformer of that,
this is a repetitive function.
So the Fourier transform just
becomes a Fourier series.
And this is an expression for
the Fourier series of this.
It basically consists
of two parts.
It's got a sort of
envelope, which is a sinc.
Basically, this is going to
consist of an infinite number
of discrete frequencies.
It's going to consist of
a constant term, which
is the zero.
It is going to consist of
a first harmonic and then
a second harmonic and a
third harmonic, and so on.
If the duty cycle
has been chosen
to be a half, i.e. it was a
square wave, then by symmetry,
it turns out that
the second harmonic
and the fourth harmonic
and all those all vanish.
So you'd only end up with the
zero, the first, the third,
the fifth, and so on.
But in general, there will
be all the orders there.
And the relative
strength of those orders
here, you can see the
size depends on the value
of this sinc function.
Actually, that's a very easy way
of seeing about the even orders
canceling.
Because what happens is, if
the duty factor is a half,
it turns out that
the even orders when
q equals even number
coincide with the zeros
of the sinc function.
And that's why they vanish.
So where this comes
from is that--
so we're saying that
this function is a--
maybe it's easier if I go on
to the next slide, I think,
which is the Fourier transform.
Yeah, so the Fourier
transform, the strength
of these components is
what we've got to find out.
And so this function
Fourier transforms
to something which is a
series of delta functions
corresponding to the different
orders, different values, of q.
And the strength of the
different components
is given by the
value of the sync.
So you can see again, if there
are some values of alpha q
which can be 0,
and therefore would
mean that those components
[? will ?] be there.
OK, so when it gets to the pupil
mask, all that's happening--
maybe we ought to
go back to the--
we'll go back to this diagram.
So you can see that
what we need to know
is, this is coming to a
focus at this point here.
But we need to know what
that distance here is.
But we need to know that
relative scaling of where
that diffraction order appears.
Oh, that was well
up here [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, so this is this lambda
f that comes in here,
because it's going
through a distance f.
So that gives the scaling
of this distribution
that you get there.
And so that's where u now is
replaced by this x double dash
over lambda f--
the scaling of that size of
that diffraction pattern.
And then this is put in
the answer, [INAUDIBLE],,
is that you get this--
oh, yeah, we're told the
alpha is the juicy fat cycle.
So that's the third.
So alpha is a third in here.
And where do we get the 1
centimeter from, George?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
I think I saw something
like this on the crib sheet.
Which he will hide, by the way.
So we've got-- all
right here, we've
got lambda equals 0.5 microns,
f equals 20 centimeters,
lambda period is
equal to 10 microns.
So that gives that lambda
f over [INAUDIBLE] lambda
is 0.5 times 20 over 10.
No, that's not--
this is microns.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
Lambda-- both lambdas
are in microns.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Oh yeah.
These are in microns.
These are in centimeters.
So this is in centimeters.
And this is equal
to 1 centimeter.
Right, OK, so that's
what's going on there.
So that's the 1 centimeter.
OK, so that's just plotting,
then, these different orders.
And so you can see here the
zero order plus 1 plus 2 plus 3,
so on.
But the screen blocks
out all the ones,
except for these central ones.
And so this thing, these
relative strengths,
must come from--
well, there's a factor
of third at the
front is this one.
And then this is
multiplied by the value
of sinc of a third, which must
give the rest of this thing
here.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
And so I have
posted in the website a
supplement to this lecture.
So in the supplement,
I have worked
out all these
calculations-- how you
compute the sinc of 1 over 1/3,
sinc of 2 over 1/3, and so on.
So you can see some more
details in the website.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, OK.
You remember a
sinc, you've defined
the sine of pi x over pi x.
Remember that?
So that's the way that
people will usually
define a sinc of x equals
sine of pi x over pi x.
All right, so it's
defined in that way,
because then lots of nasty
pi's and things cancel out
and everything else.
All right, so we've
got to multiply that
by the size of the mask.
So as it shows
here, the mask going
from minus 1.5 centimeters to
plus 1.5 centimeters, which
means that this grating
component, which
is at 2 centimeters,
doesn't get through.
So that's what gets
through the aperture.
And then we Fourier
transform that again.
And so the delta
function transforms
to an exponential-- a
shifted delta function,
and corresponds to exponential.
And therefore, our output--
this f was the
same in this case.
The two f's of the two
[INAUDIBLE] lens were the same.
So we get 1 over
lambda f again there.
AUDIENCE: What will happen if
we make the width of this mask
minus 2 to plus 2?
Will there be any diffraction
due to this second order?
COLIN SHEPPARD: Well, if it was
exactly minus 2 to the plus 2,
then I guess if it
really was exactly there,
you'd expect half of it
to get through this order.
I mean normally, we would
assume it either lets it through
or doesn't let it through.
So if you made the size of the
aperture 2.5, then of course
this next order would
get through, wouldn't it?
AUDIENCE: But if it
is exact [INAUDIBLE],,
that means do we
have to consider
the diffraction of [INAUDIBLE]?
COLIN SHEPPARD: No, I
think that effectively, I
think you have to say that
half of it got through.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Actually, that's correct.
Because in actuality,
the grating is finite.
So these are not
delta functions.
They're sinc patterns.
So if you place the
grating at exactly 2,
then you allow 1/2 of the
sinc to go through, right?
So therefore, 1/2
is [INAUDIBLE]..
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, that's
a very good way of thinking.
Here, we started off
by saying that this
is a continuous
repetitive grating.
And so we can think of it in
terms of a Fourier series.
But of course, it's not
actually infinitely big.
I guess it's not going to be
more than a few light years
across.
So this is multiplied by
another rect function, really.
So the Fourier transform of this
whole thing multiplied by rect
is something
convolved with a sinc.
So each of these things is
not really a delta function.
But it's really a
very narrow sinc,
which depends on the
size of our grating.
.
So the point George
is making is,
if you think of it as
a sinc, then it really
would be letting
through half of it.
I think mathematically, it'd
have to be like that as well.
You get used to
these when you do--
you must remember from solving
partial differential equations,
when you do the
boundary conditions,
you always have to do
that sort of thing.
It seems a bit of a cheat, but--
OK, so this is putting
the numbers in, then.
So this is the three components.
These are these root 3
over 2 pi's we had there.
And then finally, these
two combined together
to make a cosine.
And our final
amplitude of our image
is going to be a
constant plus of cosine.
You notice that it's not--
the amplitude of
this is not the same
as the amplitude of that, of
course, because of the fact
that it was a this
rectangular grating.
Yeah, and finally, though,
as I just mentioned briefly
a little while ago,
what you actually
see is not the amplitude.
What you see is the
intensity, which
is the modulus square
of the amplitude.
So you remember, we
said that we normally
are going to call the intensity
just the modulus square
of the amplitude.
There perhaps should be
some halves and funny things
out there if we were
really doing it according
to the Poynting vector.
But normally, we don't
bother with that.
We just say it's
the modulus square.
So the modulus
square of this, we're
going to get this squared and
twice the product of these two,
and then this one squared.
So we get this term
in Cos squared.
And then you have to remember
your formulae that you learn
in maths, Cos 2 theta equals 1
minus 2 cosine squared theta,
which allows us the right
Cos squared theta is
1 plus Cos theta over 2.
So this Cos squared, we can
now replace by a constant plus
a cosine of twice the angle.
And so this is the
constant bit, and this is
the cosine of twice the angle.
All right, so that gives a
another harmonic in the image.
So that's something that
people are a bit confused
by sometimes, first of all.
Because we've gone
through a lot of talk
about how it's only the first
time on it that's gone through.
But actually now, when
we look at the intensity,
we've now got a second
harmonic that's appearing
in the final intensity.
So note, the second
harmonic term intensity
due to the magnitude
square operation.
This term explains the ringing
in coherent low-pass filtering
systems.
So the ringing is the wiggles
you get on the sharp edge.
Right, and that's a sketch
of what it looks like.
So it doesn't look quite
like a cosine grating
anymore, because
when you square it,
the low values get depressed
more than the high values.
So it makes it look
more peaky, like that.
OK, so perhaps
we'll start again.
I was just waiting for one
of our people to come back.
Ah, well, there we are.
Just in time.
OK, so yeah, before we carry on,
then, there was a question just
before the break.
So we're going to
have a question.
AUDIENCE: OK, actually,
I have two questions.
The first question regarding
the physical meaning
of the low-pass filter, just
now in the previous slide.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
OK, so the question
is about the low-pass filter.
So you remember in--
perhaps I'll draw
something from electronics.
So you remember from
your hi-fi amplifier.
So this is frequency.
So these are high frequencies
and these are low frequencies.
So this corresponds to
[? ah! ?] And this corresponds
to [? uh. ?]
And if we multiply this by some
function that looks like that,
this is what we call
a low-pass filter,
because which we let
through the low frequencies
and we stop the
high frequencies.
So the same is true here.
So when we say low-pass,
we mean that we
let through the spots which
are close to the axis,
and stop the ones that
are far from the axis.
So that's the first question.
Then there's another one.
AUDIENCE: The second
one is regarding
the Abbe's rule because
Abbe's rule tell us if we can
[INAUDIBLE] two orders of the
wave, we can form an image.
But just [INAUDIBLE] even
with three orders of the wave,
we still get very [INAUDIBLE]
compared to that original one.
So I wanted to check
out what is the reason.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Right, OK, so this
is going back to Abbe's
rule, which I don't know--
I've never really heard
what he said, actually.
But have you got that
in a book or something?
It's probably in Chinese, is it?
But anyway, the Chinese
Abbe came up with this rule
that you must have at least--
well, we gave an
example just now,
didn't we, where you
only had one beam.
One order got through, and
we didn't get an image,
because you're
obviously not going
to get any interference if
you've only got one beam.
So according to Abbe, you've got
to have two beams interfering
in order to get some variation
in amplitude in the image.
And so he says at
least two, I guess.
So if you think of these,
you could let throw the--
last time we had the 0 and
the plus 1 and the minus 1,
which is three beams.
And the point that was
made in the question
was that, although we
got an image, it was
wasn't a very good image.
So I think that's
probably right.
I guess Abbe's rule is
all to do with resolution
of an optical system--
the smallest detail you can see.
But it doesn't necessarily
mean that you're
going to get a good image.
And changing the
relative strengths,
we're going to see this in
lots of examples now, actually.
I guess the whole of
the rest of this lecture
will be about these--
more examples of stopping
beams and so on, and changing
beams and seeing what
it does to the pattern.
And so very often,
what you'll find,
then, is you get something
which is maybe not a good image
of the original object.
But it's an image, which is
much better than nothing.
OK, so does that
answer the question?
OK, so we now looking
at a bandpass filter.
So going back to what
I was saying here,
the bandpass filter,
of course, is
something that looks like this.
A bandpass filter stops the
low frequencies and also
the high frequencies.
And so you can see here, the
optical equivalent of this,
it's now stopping
the zero order,
but allowing the first
orders to get through.
And then the later ones
would also not get through.
Oh yeah, that was
another point that George
mentioned to me during
the break that I
hadn't appreciated fully.
And that is that this
particular example, which
had this duty cycle of
a third, actually, it
turns out that the third
order of this one vanishes.
So I guess the third, the
sixth, the ninth, all these.
And this is just like we said.
That for a square wave grating,
all the even orders cancel.
So it's all to do with the
zeros of that sinc function.
We add sinc of alpha q, where
alpha is the duty cycle.
So for any duty cycle, there
will be particular values
of the particular integers for
the order, which would vanish
in the Fourier transform.
Right, so here, we're
letting through the plus 1
and the minus 1.
Did something [INAUDIBLE] there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah.
Right, yeah.
OK, so the amplitude is
going to be a 1 plus cosine.
And intensity, we're going to
get a second harmonic image,
just like we had with
the previous case.
0 and then now we're going to
go through this in more detail.
So it's the same
grating as before.
So we haven't got to work
out all that stuff again.
You remember, 1 centimeter
was where the first order was.
So we've got this series
of these different grating
components.
And these ones are 0,
as I just described.
The next one wouldn't be 0.
And we're putting this
masking, which is just
going to let throw these two.
And so mathematically,
we can write mask
as being the sum
of two rectangles--
rectangle, another rectangle.
So then it lets through
those two components
and stops the others.
So we've got these
two delta functions.
And then we just got to do
a Fourier transform again.
Each of the delta functions
produces a plane wave--
[INAUDIBLE] complex exponential.
We're then going to
add those together.
And we've got to change
the [? interdistance, ?] of
course, and then combine
these two complex exponentials
to make a cosine.
And then finally, we've
got to square it again
in order to get the
intensity [? out. ?]
So notice what we get now.
You see we get
the constant term.
You see, here, it's just cosine.
There's no constant term anymore
because the constant term
is gone.
So because when we square
it, we get Cos squared.
The Cos squared, we go
into double angles again.
We get a constant plus a cosine.
And so you see that actually,
we get an image where
the first harmonic
doesn't appear at all,
but the second harmonic does.
So this comes back to
your question in a way.
You end up with getting
an image which is actually
really not like the object.
Because you see that this
has got twice the frequency
of this, although Abbe says
that you can get an image,
he doesn't say that you
can get a correct image.
And in this case, you could
be very confused by this.
You could look in your
microscope at something
and you could see this.
And you'd be completely
mistaken about the object that
was actually producing this,
because it's actually twice as
big as what you expect.
So--
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Oh, yeah.
You frightened me.
AUDIENCE: If you grab
just the zero order
and say the first order,
but not the minus 1,
you get the same period
as the original grating?
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Yeah, I guess so.
Would that be right, George?
If you take this one and
this one, so you've got--
and then you square it.
You're going to get
1 plus an e to the i.
You're going to-- yeah,
he's working it out.
He's working it out.
We'll have a race, shall we?
You're going to have a 1
plus e to the [INAUDIBLE] i
something or other.
And then this module is squared.
And then you can take out an
e to the i something over 2.
You've got the answer?
Yeah.
Something like that.
So this is cosine.
So you're going to end
up with cosine squared.
It's the same as this, isn't it?
[INAUDIBLE]?
It would just be the phase term.
No, it can't be, because
it's half as far apart.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, you
got the first harmonic,
because it's the
square of half of it.
Yeah.
OK, so it's double half of it.
So you do get the
first harmonic, yeah.
You're quite correct.
But it might work
for this object.
But I guess there'd be other
objects, which would also
produce funny results.
And of course, as we know--
well, some of us know.
Most of you won't know.
But for example,
[INAUDIBLE] will
know that if you have a
mask, which is actually
metric like that, it's
going to have some quite
interesting properties.
So I don't know
whether you're going
to go through these
at some later point.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Maybe in the exam.
OK, so everyone [INAUDIBLE]
up on asymmetric gratings.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yes,
single-sideband modulation.
Yeah.
And what's the
other word for it?
What's this, when they
measure the flow of the--
in aerodynamics?
Schlieren.
It's basically Schlieren.
OK, and now we're looking
at a tilted illumination.
So same sort of system
as the last one,
but we're now not illuminating
it where the plane wave along
the axis.
We're going to tilt this.
And so what we find if
we've got a grating,
and we illuminate
it with a plane
wave, what do we find happens
if we tilt the plane wave?
Have you come across this--
you did this
earlier on, did you?
I don't think I was
there for this one.
But actually, all that
happens is it just
tilts the diffraction pattern.
Very simple.
So you can see
now, the zero order
is still in this direction.
And all of the other orders
just move [INAUDIBLE]..
They all rotate
through the same angle.
This is actually only true
if you can think of this
as being a thin grating.
And if you go into theory of
volume holograms and things
like that, then you'll
find that things
become much more complicated.
The relative strengths of the
gratings can change and so on.
But this is a thin grating, so
that you can use this property
that you just multiply it
by the transmit transmission
of the grating, then
that will be the case.
So you can see what
that's going to do.
All the gratings move up,
which means that they all
get moved up there as well.
So you see the zero
order grating, which
was appearing down at the
origin, is now tilted upwards
and appears at this point here.
So with this bandpass
filter that we've chosen,
we now get the
zero order through.
So we're getting the
0 to through this one.
And we're getting the minus
2 order through this one.
Right, so we illuminate the
grating with an off-axis plane
wave at an angle of 2.865
degrees, which is obviously
very carefully designed, so that
this grating this grating order
moves through from here to here.
So what happens?
OK, so it's just describing
what I just said.
Yeah, this is just describing
why that happens, then,
in terms of multiplying the--
this tilted wave is
just going to have
a complex exponential
phase variation like this.
So you multiply
that by the grating.
And then it's just
[INAUDIBLE] this result
of rotating the thing.
OK, so there are
the grating orders.
The zero order one is this one.
And this is the plus and minus
1 and the plus and minus 2.
And so we let through those two.
So we're now letting
through the zero
order and the minus 2 order.
So it's a bit like the
one in the question.
But now it's the minus 2
order, not the minus 1 order.
So this is going to be another
example where it doesn't give
a very good image of it from
that result. OK, so yeah, let's
just [INAUDIBLE].
Here we are.
So it's 1 centimeters.
That magic angle was
designed so that they're all
shifted by 1 centimeter.
So after passing
through the mask,
we just get those
two components.
And so these are
the two components.
Ah, but [INAUDIBLE]
no, it isn't.
Yeah, that's right,
because there's still--
it's a bit more complicated
than where I was--
it's tricky, this.
So not only of course that
we let through the zero
order and the minus 2 order.
But those orders have got
this complex phase shift.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
exactly, exactly.
Because of the phase,
because of the--
yeah.
OK, so that's what I'm saying.
Although this is a zero
order and a minus 2 order,
they're actually shifted.
And so when you do
the Fourier transform,
they're just as
though they were there
plus 1 and the minus 1 order.
And that's neat.
Very interesting.
AUDIENCE: But with
different amplitudes.
COLIN SHEPPARD: But with
different amplitudes given
by these two strengths here.
And then-- yeah, so then we
have to put the values of u
in terms of the x.
And then we combine
the two exponentials.
Well, can't do that anymore.
Can we?
Oh yes, we can.
AUDIENCE: Well, you can,
but [INAUDIBLE] sine and the
cosine.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, exactly.
So have you actually
done that, then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Right,
so you've got to do
the modulus square of this.
So you're going to have this
squared plus this squared.
AUDIENCE: Plus [INAUDIBLE].
COLIN SHEPPARD: Oh yeah,
OK, so [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, of course you are.
So then twice the
products of these two.
And-- OK.
Is that right?
No, sorry.
That's not right, is it?
AUDIENCE: The magnitude
of the first [INAUDIBLE]
the magnitude of the
second plus [INAUDIBLE]..
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Yeah, that's right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: OK, and
this is what it looks like.
Ta-da.
OK, so the field is
the first harmonic.
The intensity is
the second harmonic
because of the squaring.
And the contrast is 0.7.
Right, so again we end up with
a bad image as it's shifted,
because it's double frequency.
And also, the contrast
is reduced in this case,
because the strength of the
two beams was not the same.
This is calculating
here the contrast.
This is the normal definition
of contrast fringes--
the difference over the sum.
And it comes to 0.7062.
In the previous case, of
course, the contrast was 1.
Right, another example--
a new pupil mask
consisting of two holes,
each of diameter 1 centimeter
and centered further away
from the axis plus or minus
2 centimeters from the
optical axis respectively.
What is the intensity observed
at the output image plane?
Right, so at least it's
told us the 2 centimeters.
We know where that is.
We don't have to worry
about working out
what 0.3479 degrees is.
We know that the first
order was at 1 centimeter.
So the second order is
where the aperture is.
going to get through,
the plus 2 and the minus 2.
And did not appear,
then, up there?
Right, so the second harmonic
is going to get through.
And when you do
the square of that,
you're going to get
the fourth harmonic.
So this is going through
the mass of that, then.
So we've got just
these two components.
So these have now
got 2 centimeters
in, rather than 1 centimeter.
So that means that you
get a 2 multiplied in here
that wasn't there before.
So that's where the
second harmonic comes in.
And then when you do the
square, again, you're
only going to get the
cosine and no constants.
And then you do Cos squared and
change that into double angles,
or fourth angles, actually.
And now we're going to
see what it looks like.
And now, it's even worse
an image of what we wanted.
So I guess this is maybe
telling us what we shouldn't do,
rather than what we should do.
AUDIENCE: Got another question.
Is this is still
assuming f1 equals f2?
And what happens if
f2 is smaller than f1?
COLIN SHEPPARD: All it
would do, if you changed
the relative values of an
f1 an f2, all it would do
is change the size
of the final image.
If you think about this system--
let's go back to one where
it shows that-- there we are.
You can see that the relative
distances from the axis only
depend on this part
of the optical system.
And then after the
pupil mask, we've
already decided,
then, what orders
get into the final image.
And then the final part,
all that's going to do
is just change the relative
size of the final image you see.
Right, now we're going to do
another bit more complicated
one--
a phase pupil mask.
And so what this
is shown as is, you
can see it's got an opaque
part of the screen here.
And then in the
central part, it's
transparent, but it's got
some sort of structure there--
some diffractive
dielectric element,
which changes the relative
phase of this order compared
with the other orders.
So the question is, what's
that going to do to your image?
So the rest of the system
is completely the same.
So this is what we are
considering putting in there.
It doesn't matter what
the thickness of this
is, because all
that's going to do
is change the relative
phase of all of these.
So it won't affect how
they interfere with each.
It will just change the phase
of the final image, which
you don't see anyway.
But what is important
is this bit here.
The thickness of this
s equals 0.25 microns,
and the wavelength was
half of 0.5 microns.
So that's lambda by 2.
So that means it changes
the phase by 180 degrees.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Ah, n minus 1.
the next slide.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, n minus 1.
So it's not going to do that.
Take it back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD:
It's [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, this is known as a phase
pupil mask or a pupil phase
mask, or a mask pupil phase.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Yeah, that's right.
So that must be in
the next lecture,
because it's not in this one.
So let's get down to
the real application.
OK, so George said that I
would have just failed the exam
because I forgot the minus 1.
Of course, this light
goes through the glass.
But this light goes through
the glass and then the air.
So to work out the
relative phases of these,
you have to look at the relative
change in the refractive index
times the optical thickness.
So this is 0.25 microns,
and this is at 0.25 microns
divided by the wavelength.
And it's going to be
multiplied by 1.5 minus 1.
So this is assuming it's glass.
So this means that the
phase change is pi over 2.
So not pi, but pi over 2.
OK, so exactly the same grating.
These are all the orders.
And so you see, first of all,
we get rid of these outer ones.
We let through just these three.
But of those, we're
also going to change
the relative phase of this one
relative to the other, too.
That doesn't matter, of
course, in your sum whether you
change the phase of
this or you change
the phase of the other two.
Certainly, the relative phase,
which is the important thing.
OK, so these are the
three conditions, then.
For the ones that are not
don't get through at all,
the strength of those is zero.
Then here, we're taking these
ones to be of strength one,
and this one in the center to
be strength of e to the i phi.
And we know that
phi is pi over 2.
So this is e to the i pi
over 2, which is just i.
Is that right?
Why have we got this i
minus 1 then, George?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
[INAUDIBLE] So one way
to write this pupil function
is as a rect that is as big
as the opening.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah, OK.
Sorry, yeah.
So you can think of this as
being the whole thing minus--
well, this on top of
the whole rectangle.
Otherwise, you'd have to do this
little rectangle and this bit
a rectangle and this bit of
rectangle as three things.
So you could do it either
of those ways, I guess.
But the way that George
has done it here,
it's the rectangle, of
the whole [? lot, ?]
it's all of this
minus the central one,
plus the central one
with the phase change.
So that's the minus
the one that's
not there plus the one that is
there where the phase changed.
And yeah, so now--
well of course, we still get
all these delta functions.
But now we've got
some i's coming in.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Just one i.
COLIN SHEPPARD:
Just one i, yeah.
And then these two combine
to produce cosine still.
I guess if you change the phase
of one relative to the other,
it'd be more complicated.
But these two produce a cosine.
So we've got an i plus a cosine.
And then we do the
modulus square of that.
And the modulus square
of that, of course,
is you're not going to get a
cross product term are you,
because these two are
in phase quadrature.
So when you do the modulus
square, you're only going--
is that right?
Yeah.
You're going to get this
squared plus this squared.
And this squared, you can
write as these two terms
when you do the double angle.
And I guess the next
one, we're going
to see what it looks like.
Ta-da, this is
what it looks like.
First harmonic in field,
second harmonic in intensity
because of the squaring.
And again, the contrast is
now much reduced, actually,
in this case--
down to 0.25.
So I guess this hasn't turned
out to be a very [INAUDIBLE]
strategy.
This lecture seems to
be mainly showing you
what you shouldn't do when
you make your microscope.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: [LAUGHS]
COLIN SHEPPARD: OK,
so now we're going
to go on to think
of this in terms
of what we call a
point spread function
of the low-pass filter.
So do you remember, going
back to our analogies
with electronics, we can
think of-- any electronics you
can either think of
your hi-fi amplifier
as being like a
black box, don't you?
And you put in something
and you get out something.
And you can either
think of what happens
was inside there as being like
an h of t, an impulse response.
Or you can think of it as
being a frequency response.
So there are two
different ways of thinking
about this black box.
The same is true in this case.
So up until now,
we've been thinking
of this in terms of the
frequency response, what
frequencies get into the image.
And now we're going to think
of what that means in terms
of the point spread function.
We've come across the point
spread function before,
of course.
So the point spread
function is basically
the image of a point object.
And our point objects, we
make by having a screen
with a very small hole in.
So this, then, is
going to expand.
It reached the lens.
It's going to be
collimated because we
were seeing this on the axis.
This collimated beam is going
to arrive at our pupil mask.
Part of this collimated
beam is going
to go through the aperture.
It's going to get to a lens.
It's then going
to be focused down
and produce a converging wave
to form a spot on the screen.
So this is what we think of as--
the final spot is going to be
what we call the point spread
function h of x, y.
OK, so how do we work out
this point spread function?
So what we do is, we can
again work through this system
in terms of Fourier transforms.
This is a delta function.
So the Fourier transform
of a delta function
is just a constant.
We multiply the constant
by the pupil mask.
And then we've got
another system here,
which does another
Fourier transform.
So what we're going to get
in the final plane, the image
of a point object, is
going to be the Fourier
transform of the pupil mask.
And yeah, so it
makes the point here
that we have to be careful, of
course, how we scale things.
And of course, the
scaling is going
to depend on the relative
sizes of these f1 and f2
as well, of course.
So, example-- if we got
the low pass filter,
so 0 is in the center.
It lets through the
low frequencies,
stops the outer frequencies.
So this is the pupil mask.
What does the point spread
function of that give?
And so we're assuming that
the input transparency
is delta x on the axis.
So this is illuminated on-axis.
The field after the pupil
mask is just the same
as the pupil mask.
And then we Fourier
transform that,
and it's going to give a sinc.
That the Fourier
transform of rect is sinc.
And here, we've got the
relative sizes of this
as well, so that we
know how big it is.
And so that the amplitude
point spread function, then,
is this Fourier transform
rescaled with this x dashed
over lambda f.
We replace the u by the
x [INAUDIBLE] lambda f.
And this finally,
then, is our answer.
Which three times
is it saying there?
This three, or is that three?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Yeah.
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
OK, because the energy
has to be conserved
by this thing.
So you remember,
there's this theorem
in Fourier transforms
again that says
the area under the
function squared
is equal to the area under
the Fourier transform squared.
So it's conservation of energy.
And so this is the amplitude
point spread function.
It's sinc, so it goes negative.
Sinc is sine pi x over pi x.
So it goes negative.
So that's why it's plotted here.
This is 0.
It wiggles up and down
above the 0 [? light. ?]
And so of course, if you looked
at the image of a point object,
you'd see the modulus
square of this.
Just like when we looked at
our examples of the grating,
we finally look at the
actual intensity, rather than
the amplitude.
The intensity, of course,
is always positive.
So you'd actually be looking
at the square of that.
But if you're trying to think
of this thing as being--
what we're going to carry
on to say, of course,
is in Fourier space,
or in Fourier domain,
the spatial frequencies
of the object
are multiplied by the mask.
In terms of real space, you're
going to get a convolution.
The product becomes
a convolution.
So we're going to convolve our
objects with an amplitude point
spread function.
But we have to do it with
the amplitude point spread
function, find the final
the total amplitude
in the image, and then
the modulus square
to find the final the intensity.
OK, and this is an example
of the point spread
function of this phase
filter we looked at.
The pupil mask, this is
the same as we had before.
So this is its modulus.
This is the phase.
And if you calculate the
point spread function of this,
it comes to this.
This is the modulus.
This is the phase.
So you can see that that is why
we got a pretty horrible image.
It's because it's got a very
nasty point spread function.
[INAUDIBLE] point spread
function, for a start,
it's got these very
large side lobes,
which normally we don't like.
We normally like to have
our point spread function
to be nicely narrow and smooth,
and without the big side lobes.
And then more than
that, it's also
got these horrible phase
jumps, which I think
are very likely to produce
a pretty awful image, which
is probably what we saw.
So this goes through the
sum of actually doing that.
So this is the same as
we had before, then--
the big rectangle minus
the little rectangle
with the phase.
And then we've got to do the
Fourier transform of that.
And so the way we've
done it here, then,
we just got the sum
of two rectangles.
Each of them becomes a sinc.
But you've got this i here
you have to be careful of.
And then finally, we work
out the modulus square
of the part of the
point spread function
and the phase of the point
spread function right so
this is the modulus square
of the point spread function.
So these side lobes are
actually quite huge--
quite big.
OK, yeah, that's just looking at
the difference between the two,
then.
So if we have our
low-pass filter--
so this is what I was saying
about these being huge.
You see the low-pass
filter, these side lobes
are pretty small by comparison.
I guess you could use some sort
of shaded aperture, or maybe
an aperture with some structure
that would allow you to make
those side lobes even smaller.
This is this process that's
sometimes called apodization.
Apodization means
to cut off the feet.
I think if George
was giving the talk,
he'd say something
about the Greek
for feet being something
to do with pod.
Right, there we are.
OK, we are over time, really.
[INAUDIBLE] stop now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
COLIN SHEPPARD: Yeah,
maybe that's a good point.
I think that's good.
You've got the concept of
the point spread function.
Now you've got a week to
think about the point spread
function.
And then next time,
it will be very clear.
OK, so any questions
from either side?